all right guys bang bang Darius I
thought a great place to start would be
Global liquidity this thing seems to be
driving all asset prices what do you got
for us yeah absolutely so what I want to
do just real quickly this week uh was
help investors kind of understand what's
going on with global liquidity every
month in what we call our macro scouting
report we put together about 30 or 40
slides particularly as it relates to
Global liquidity and U.S liquidity so I
just want to give some of the key
highlights off from the most recent
sci-tech uh for your for your audience
to give them a sense of kind of what we
do the kind of work we do on the subject
so as you mentioned Global liquidity is
a key driver assets and the chart I'm
showing our Global liquidity proxy which
is the global central bank balance sheet
plus global money supply plus global FX
reserves minus gold showing that on a
year-overy rate of change basis relative
to Global Equity market cap and relative
to bitcoin as you can see it is a key
driver of risk assets
so when we start to go look at the asset
prices and asset markets and their
response to this what do you have yeah
so uh this second chart here we show the
blue line is our Global liquidity proxy
we show that relative to the s p bitcoin
ethereum U.S treasuries and U.S
corporate credit and as you can see
those things are always co-integrated
with global liquidity I.E you know the
liquidity's high asset market prices
tend to be high when liquidity is low uh
asset prices tend to be low those
correlations can rise you know as you
can see you know it's very correlated in
the last kind of you know three or four
years particularly with respect to the s
p but if you look at sort of the last
you know two to three years with respect
to bond markets how those things have
become untethered to Global liquidity as
uh policymakers around the world have
really changed their policy rate
settings uh in the most recent quarters
and then when we look at what's driving
the global liquidity obviously we have
dollars we have FX uh volatility what
else are we looking at yeah so you and I
talked about this all the time right
like you can't just call out liquidity
and use it as an investment process
because you actually need to forecast
liquidity in order to actually make
money with this kind of information and
so what we show what we do at 40 to
macro is really try to help invest
understand what the drivers of liquidity
are and then we use our quantitative
tools and our forecasting tools with
respect to the economy and central banks
to forecast what those drivers are
likely to do in order to forecast for
Global liquidity is likely to do what
you know investable time Horizons and so
what we show in this chart is the US
dollar real effective exchange rate as
you can see that's highly inversely
correlated to Global liquidity and so
much that currency volatility which is
the chart on the right is inversely
correlated to Global liquidity as well
so if you can get the dollar right you
get currency volatility right you're
probably going to get Global liquidity
right and there's a variety of reasons
for that but you know we'll keep it
brief for that and then interest rates
also uh seem to be driving Global
liquidity yeah absolutely yeah Global
Community tends to spike after interest
rates uh Spike and uh typically it tends
to fall after interest rates fall on a
real basis and you know you typically
tend to follow uh the the bond market
volatility on inverse bases as well and
so you know what we're trying to see
what we see here is this historical
pattern of central banks chasing bond
market volatility with more Global
liquidity uh and so much that we tend to
see spikes and declines in global
liquidity after bond market volatility
has subsided so these things of um you
know these things these patterns these
relationships are very uh coincident and
consistent across time uh you know going
back to the dollar and FX volatility and
moving on to interest rate volatility as
well you know there's a few reasons why
these things tend to be inversely
correlated to Global liquidity uh the
number one reason for that in my opinion
is that you know a lot of what we see
from Global liquidity comes from the
private sector so we're all constantly
focused on central banks but the reality
is private sector actors tend to create
liquidity as well and those actors find
it very difficult particularly when
you're in a International Investment
Surplus economies like Europe and Japan
you know these these these these
economies tend to create a ton of
liquidity globally from the private
sector perspective but when they have
interest rate volatility when they have
currency volatility it makes it very
difficult for those private sector
agents to sort of you know continuously
increase the amount of dollars that's
applying across Global Capital markets
so that's when you tend to see global
liquidity weighing at the margin from
again from from private sector uh actors
and then when we start looking these
downturns in growth it seems like Global
liquidity is a second order effect or it
kind of lags behind yeah absolutely so
uh so we just spent a few minutes
talking about what drives private sector
liquidity I vis-a-vis currency
volatility interest rate volatility you
know on an inverse basis and then what
we tends to drive public sector
liquidity I.E Central Bank liquidity uh
tends to be the sort of cyclical upturns
and downturns and growth so you tend to
get more Global liquidity when you know
after a growth slowdown obviously that
tends to be it's pretty obvious there's
cause an effect there but we also have
that um in terms of how it lacks
cyclical upturns and inflation so the
next chart where we show the declines in
global liquidity tend to lag cyclical up
terms and inflation so if you want you
know more Global liquidity you tend to
want a slowing economy from a public
sector from a private sector a public
sector standpoint pardon me if you want
more liquidity from central banks you
want to slow down in growth and slow
down in inflation you want less
liquidity from the central banks you
want a you know rise in um uh growth and
a rise in inflation you want more
liquidity from private sector actors you
want a falling dollar falling interest
rate volatility falling currency
volatility you want less liquidity from
private sector actors you need a rising
dollar Rising interest rate volatility
Rising currency volatility when we look
at the liquidity cycle you are showing
that it has bottomed in 2022 what does
that mean for investors yeah so uh yeah
I think yeah we've talked about this at
nauseam as other guests have talked
about this as well but you know we're in
a liquidity cycle upturn you know it
very much bottom had a pretty secular
low uh back in October of 2022 but you
know one thing we've been consistent
about calling out this year
um particularly when we got to towards
the year-to-date highs in Bitcoin back
in April uh what you're saying hey look
Global liquidity is not this sort of
linear recovery that you know we've
historically seen in previous liquidity
Cycles typically you see a bottom and
it's just up up and away for liquidity
for you know several quarters or several
years and that's just not the case and
so we're observing here uh in 2023 which
is that middle panel there where we're
showing our Global liquidity proxy
that's the Blue Line in the top panel
we're showing on a Max drawdown basis in
the middle panel and you can see you
know it's very clearly not a linear
recovery process much like what we've
seen in previous uh Cycles when we look
at the impulse what are we seeing here
yeah so that's um so we retract the same
statistics uh Global liquidity proxy
World Equity market cap again showing in
the middle panel on the bottom panel
there the three-month uh momentum in
each of those time series and as you can
see over the last four months we've seen
Global liquidity actually Wane over the
last three four months or the last four
months uh we saw a uh a minus kind of
four trillion dollar hit to Global
liquidity on a trailing three-month
impulse basis in June that number Rose
to minus 2.94 trillion uh in July uh
it's still not you know not quite what
we want from the perspective of global
liquidity but it's definitely getting
better at the margins and that makes a
lot of sense we're moving past you know
the kind of the worst of it as it
relates to you know TGA rebuilding all
that stuff here in the US
now when we start to go and look at this
next chart I don't understand this you
don't have to explain this one to me but
we've got Global liquidity is driven by
counter cyclical and pro cyclical
factors what exactly is this showing us
yeah absolutely so as I mentioned
earlier you know it's again when we talk
about liquidity a lot of you know the
kind of the Twitter Community is really
focused on liquidity from central banks
but the reality is if you want to get
asset markets right you need to
understand liquidity from both private
sector and public sector actors so the
central banks a lot of folks care about
because they have the ability to inflect
the trend I.E if you're in a cyclical
downturn and you're you know typical
downturn and growth inflation you know
central banks and step in and say hey
look we're going to do something with
our policy that makes it easier for
private sector actors to kind of take
that and reflexively create liquidity on
the other side of that so that's why we
really care about central banks a lot
but the reality is you know the dominant
force in global liquidity is the private
sector and so you really do need to
understand kind of how these private
sector flows and how they're um how
they're impacting asset markets um and
so what we're seeing here on the
trolling three month momentum basis is
that you know if you go back and you
break over open our Global liquidity
proxy in terms of the features in that
central bank balance sheet is
Contracting globally you have a slightly
less small a slightly smaller
contraction uh in in global broad money
supply and then you're still having this
very modest build on global FX reserves
on a trailing three months the impulse
basis so again as I mentioned the
liquidity impulse has been negative for
four months it's getting slightly less
negative at the margins and that's
partially due to improving uh private
sector liquidity conditions now let's
talk about these market conditions that
continue to support Rising private
sector liquidity this is obviously
something that you've been really really
spending a lot of time on this year what
are you seeing here yeah absolutely so
uh what I show on this chart the chart
on the left shows the trailing 10-year
correlation to each of those particular
factors to the year-of-year rate of
change of our Global liquidity proxy the
chart on the right shows the the Z
scores of each of those leading
indicators the latest value of each of
those leading in coincident indicators
on a z-score basis uh there's a cyclical
three z-score uh which is a trailing
three years there's a structural disease
score which is the trailing 10 years and
what you see is that growth and
inflation which we can proxy use in the
oecd composite leading index we can
proxy using the year-over-year basis
point and change in unemployment rate or
we can proxy uh um sort of you know
those two things will help us proxy
growth and obviously inflation we use
core CPI on a year of your basis what we
see there is that based on what those
current things are reading on the on the
chart on the right we should not expect
a significant amount of public sector
liquidity over the next six months based
on the correlations between those
particular indicators relative to the
global liquidity proxy on a six-month
lead basis but on a coincident basis we
see that you know things like the move
index the currency volatility uh the US
dollar we see brain crude oil real
tenure yield all those things are
actually down under your basis on a firm
perspective of a cyclical z-scores so
it's telling you that the steel is a
decent enough environment for private
sector agents to continue creating
liquidity at the margins should they
choose to obviously animal spirits being
the kind of dominant force in that in
that process uh if and when central
banks aren't there kind of leading the
charge
last question macro narratives obviously
those things change uh With the Wind
what uh what are you seeing here and
what is this chart showing us yeah great
question so uh every morning we refresh
this table for our clients um you know
this is our uh Global liquidity monitor
uh where we're tracking it's growth
inflation and policy across all these
major economies that feed into our
Global liquidity proxy and what we show
there on the right of the systematic
trade ideas which are born out of you
know certain setups with respect to
growth certain setups with respect to
inflation or certain setups with respect
to policy and as you can see I'm from
the equity side China's got a bear
signal we got a new bear signal in the
Eurozone this morning from Eurozone
Equity perspective new bear signal in
Switzerland from that perspective and
how you get Bearer signals from the
center for our systematic process is
when you have growth selling on a
trading basis with vis-a-vis the leading
indicators and you also have negative
economic Surprises with a negative
impulse in global liquidity that's kind
of like a bearish trifecta for outcomes
and obviously if growth is accelerating
you had positive economic surprises you
had positive impulse and Global
liquidity that would be bullish uh for
stocks um you know we had both signals
for places like India and Brazil for
quite some time but those things have
recently dissipated uh to neutral
signals in recent weeks so that's
something to call out to the extent you
know anyone is on Long India or Brazil
um on the F on the fixed income side
her model spotted the um the breakdown
that we're seeing in Japanese uh the
Japanese government bond market and
ultimately that pivoted well the yield
curve control tweak uh because it
spotted a negative setup uh with respect
to Japanese bonds so how you get a
negative setup on the fixed income
Market is you have headline and core
inflation accelerating with a negative
impulse in your in the particular
country's Global liquidity proxy or not
Global than particular countries uh
liquidity proxy because we run that same
analysis for each country and we
amalgamate them to get to our Global
liquidity proxy and so obviously if you
want to be bullish on bonds you want to
see headline and core inflation
decelerating with the liquidity proxy
that's rising and then lastly with
respect to FX our model's been all over
the Bears Chinese one story all year uh
we're seeing with respect to the Chinese
one you have policy rate that's trending
lower you have a fiscal balance that's
percent turning lower as a percent of
GDP you have current account balance
that's trading lower as a percent of GDP
those things are all negative for the
currency and conversely if those things
were rising at the same time you'd have
a bullish outlook for the currency so a
lot of red a lot of down arrows in this
table right now there was a lot of green
arrows in this table you know going back
a few months ago but those things have
obviously dissipated to more neutral
signals where can we send people to find
you or 42 macro yes I mentioned so we
refresh all this analysis on a you know
every day and every morning not every
day everything is worthy of calling out
but certainly this uh this table here
that we just spoke to we refresh that
every day six days a week for 42 micro
customers and we do a big deep dive as I
mentioned on global liquidity every
month at the beginning of the month in
our macro Scotty report so definitely
come check us out we're at 42macro.com
if you can't afford our research we'd
like to think that we priced it very
very affordably but if it's a little bit
over your head then just just follow us
on Twitter uh we're 42 macro weather
do a fantastic job I literally learned
something every single time we talk so I
appreciate you doing this periodically
and we'll do it again of course brother
I appreciate you man you be good now
this video is brought to you by start
engine the biggest fortunes aren't made
on Wall Street they used to be made
there but now they're being made in
private markets consider Mike Walsh he
put five thousand dollars into Uber he's
just a regular dude turning it over 24
million dollars such opportunities were
once held behind closed doors reserved
for those with connections or vast
fortunes but not anymore start engine is
now going to tear down that glass
ceiling and make startup Investments
possible for you and me the company is
led by Howard marks the co-founder of
gaming giant Activision and they got 1.7
million users that have put in over 1.2
billion dollars of transactions on the
platform but the best part is the
platform's not even backed by
traditional Venture capitalists it's
backed basically by the community
they've raised over 75 million dollars
in crowdsource funding to date go check
them out at startengine.com you can open
up a start engine account today and you
can explore live investing opportunities
with starting investing amounts as
little as a hundred dollars
startengine.com go check them out today